you guys uh you girls
you in between is
we're here we have one of our favorite
people in the whole world comedian host
singer
um
reality TV hammer
Nikki Glazer hi guys
we never do intros it's so weird yeah so
it's so awkward I always like feel bad
for people who have to do them for me we
were talking about this at The Comedy
Store when someone has to bring you up
because there's no host oh yeah and you
have to like I hate listening to someone
are you talking about when you said Owen
Wilson oh yeah are you bringing up when
you literally called Owen Smith a strong
black man Owen Wilson
and when I said I thought I had said oh
and
benjamination which we do not mix Owen
Benjamin and strong black men I don't
like that go together oh and so I said I
said Owen Wilson I thought I said Owen
Benjamin knowing that I know that's not
Owen Smith's name so then I grabbed the
mic again and I go oh I'm sorry no he's
canceled and then they're all confused
like why is Owen Wilson we kind of wish
it was a little bit it's like another
movie
I did like that one right remember when
he almost yeah he did the the ultimate
canceling yeah and went to heaven what
do you mean oh the ultimate camera
it's too comfy that was I've been
practicing they were like one two one
because that's how she keeps beating his
brother did that on uh the Royal Tenon
bombs yeah favorite movie and then again
oh that's my favorite too Richie right
oh my God now yeah we kind of Follow
that did that is your type who suicidal
suicidal tennis players
tortured I love Excellence like oh wait
also brother
yes oh my God wait why abroad what are
you talking about oh well you gotta cut
that yeah I have a big brother [ __ ]
energy she's a Serial brother [ __ ]
yeah I just I accidentally [ __ ]
Brothers
um who are most evil Brothers no no no I
also my own brother
like has sex with black guys and the
whole time that's what we meant I have
had sex with more black guys than any
other race
is that is that what you're trying to
say
thank you
thank you so much and the award goes
give her the banana give her the no not
that banana the bigger one
Carlos don't do that they don't know
that you just play with the [ __ ] you
can't do that to your bananas anymore
you're not allowed to yeah
no I had one I got a this is like I
don't know if I would get canceled for
this now but it was like four years ago
I went to Carney's the like it's a train
restaurant it's like a train yeah like
the yeah it's like a trolley for the
people at home it's a trolley restaurant
you know what I'm talking about at um
near the comedy store and I went and
they I got this like giant chocolate
covered banana it's like one of my
favorite desserts yeah and I was like
holding it it looked like a dolphin it
goes it reminds me of a dolphin a Miami
Dolphin
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
it's the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available a hundred percent
online plus it's affordable
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime it couldn't be simpler
no waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhealth.com trash Tuesday that's
betterhelp
health.com trash Tuesday what if I told
you that you could grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show go
to neutriful.com use code trash to save
15 off your first month this is their
best offer anywhere only available to us
customers for a limited time
free shipping on every order that's 15
off at neutriful
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com code trash
whether you're starting small or scaling
up shipstation makes ship happen ship
more and grow more with ship station
this holiday season give yourself the
gift of stress-free holiday shipping use
promo code trash Tuesday today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's shipstation.com
promo code trash Tuesday we all love it
we know you will too oh yeah guys the
holidays came early this year ladies and
if you're not sure what to get your man
in your life then look no further than
our friends at manscape get free
shipping and 20 off by going to
manscape.com and using trash Tuesday at
checkout that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped.com and use code
trash Tuesday get your man a gift you'll
both enjoy the gift of manscaped his
jingle balls will thank you I'm so glad
you took that one can't believe I did it
I was so proud of you thank you hello
sluggies it's so good to see you I'm
having so much fun on this episode
um I am going to be at Wise Guys for New
Year's in Las Vegas that's December 30th
and 31st it's going to be so fun please
come party with me baby I'll then be
doing a one-nighter in Burbank at
Flappers I'm gonna be in Wisconsin in
January I'm going to be in Florida in
February and March and I'm going to be
in Canada in April a lot more shows to
come so go to Annie leverman.com shows
also stick around after the show go over
to youtube.com Annie Letterman to watch
my new solo podcast Annie wood we've
been having such a good time and it's so
amazing
um to see you guys there so peace hi
guys I am going to be doing stand-up in
Phoenix January 6th and 7th you can get
tickets at estheronice.com and also
check out my solo show my pleasure it's
available wherever you listen to your
podcasts
um wait what were you saying about oh
you and uh you like guys that are super
talented excellent so if you're gonna be
a plumber I need I need to know like
when I check the Yelp reviews of your of
the plumbing company your name needs to
be like go see you know Douglas he's a
number one in this company I need
Excellence it doesn't have to be a very
impressive field but you better be at
the top of it not the Plumbing's not
impressive
Doug your ass dug your class okay
he will dig in there and he will get you
that makes sense Bobby was excellent
right yeah like you saw Excellence there
of like he's the funniest right and if
you work for a utility company I need
you to be at least superintendent like I
need you to be
climbing up the ranks fast I like a man
that's on the streets going door to door
a Jehovah's Witness a Mormon someone to
be respected in their field like I don't
need them to be respected by everyone
else but I need everyone who's in the
know to be like this is the 100 yeah 100
and like okay so with Todd when I met
him in the basement of The Comedy Store
he was doing basement Todd he was like
so like too good for his position and
people only a few people noticed but it
was like the people in charge like
someone was like you're like the Martin
Scorsese of the space and I'm like
that's what I'm talking about and then I
decorated I plucked him from the
basement and I just put him around my
friends and I didn't say anything and he
just got hired by everyone and now he
works on Netflix shows yes because they
saw it yeah excellent underrated
excellence
now Carlos have you ever been good at
anything
Annie we're so early in the episode you
can't lean on me I like to get you no I
want you to be wait what is Carlos's
history I don't I don't know oh it's so
funny where did you get him to say yeah
no Annie has a is pushing my buttons
lately with Excellence if you want to
say that do you think I'm pushing your
buttons I think you do it on purpose are
you serious yeah I thought I thought we
just needed the work to get done I'm
just kidding I'm joking Carlos is I'll
tell you what he's really he gets mad
and starts throwing things it does get
scary he's been excellent at being my
rebound boy after my breakup not
necessarily sexually rebound but some
kind of like emotional rebound oh yeah
for like all of my pent-up sections that
make you feel just like not sexual like
I'm he does everything else I mean I do
work with kalila yeah and Bobby so I'm
obviously the sexual aspect is a little
tricky sure he's also Bobby's rebound
boy
I know Bobby's always asking me about
friends he's like are you dating what's
going on with you he's always like with
you two no just in general in general
him and Andrew always yeah and what's
the answer
um no not really oh busy with work he's
married to his job so well tell us your
butt dial I did I'm sorry well Kyla says
it was fake a girl I don't know why I'm
imagining like a dial inside your butt
I was like is this a new butt plug it
tells you like what time it is
you put it in front of the sun you see
where the shadow is you know if it's
past noon or not
I met a girl last week
um like in a work setting and she had
just got my number and I got a butt dial
while I was at Bad friend's Sunday and I
was like huh I wonder why this girl's
calling me so I called her back and then
she responded with a bunch of question
marks and was like oh my bad I didn't
mean to call you it was a butt dial but
then I got super embarrassed and I
brought it up to kalila and she was like
that's a move for sure
hundred percent I've done that I think
it can be a move but the but she seemed
confused have you talked to her since
yeah we saw I saw her uh like two days
ago and it was like fun and normal it
wasn't she's been watching all of your
stories though okay so that is the how
much what did we do before stories to
know if someone was into us
so you're like oh I mean you can tell if
you know you guys are even talking about
on the last episode about
um people blocking you and feeling like
that's a sign that like oh good I'm yeah
cause like it's it's flattering when
someone blocks you but like you can tell
when girls are starting to be threatened
by or like people just find out who you
are or like or or and then there's the
thing of like watching one of your
stories because sometimes I watch it
will jump to someone's story because
I've been watching the person before and
I'll go oh [ __ ] I don't want them to
think I'm watching this and then I get
off it but sometimes like back in my
single days I would want to get
someone's attention and I would only
watch the first one and then purposely
not watch the other rest so sometimes I
don't know if they're doing that move to
me because I've we've done that it's so
funny like boys are like not paying
attention to us
like we'd be really good lesbians well
Carlos you're not this
with the whole butt dial thing I was
telling him that
um sometimes like the spirit moves me to
call a boy that I like and I think that
can sometimes be either intimidating out
of the blue like it there's no but I'm
like oh I really just I had a thought in
my mind I feel strong I feel chatty I'm
gonna call this boy I like right and I
do that but then they don't pick up so
when they don't pick up now I'm
embarrassed because I was coming in hot
and then I immediately text them oh
sorry butt dial and they're like all
good that takes it away oh I think that
okay so wait a second did you get a call
and it I did you pick up and you just
heard like chatter that wasn't for you
you missed it
I would never think to do that and say
butt dial when I get insecure after they
don't pick up it just eliminates my
shame of being like like impulsive
sometimes because I can do that if I
like have a crush on some I'm like I'm
just gonna I can't you can't do that for
a text that you're like hey I haven't
heard from you in a while while and I
think it's really [ __ ] and you send this
whole thing you're like oh sorry but
okay I've done that to another person
that we have the same circumstances but
I had a boy call me out recently and
he's like are you sure that was a butt
dial and I was like oh he's on to my
[ __ ] I'm like it was it was absolutely a
butt dial he's like three times
it's like it's [ __ ] like 11 30 p.m
yeah you're like I accidentally text
just waxed
my bad I didn't mean it I was stupid by
car guy
um what do you guys think about this new
um Trend in Korean bars I I don't think
there are any of them yet in the United
States but it's basically like they're
they're dating bars you go with a group
of four of your girlfriends and um men
go with group of four of their friends
and with the idea that you're going to
co-mingle but it's um
um if you were to bring three of your
friends along with you would there be a
strategy to which friends you would
bring
to a dating bar I think I think this is
a great idea because you want your
friends there when you if you're going
to a dating bar it's like we're here to
meet people that we're gonna have sex
with which is a lot of pressure and it's
like right we're talking about this I
think on tigerbelly of like I hate going
on dates because you sit down and you're
just like are we gonna have sex or maybe
end up together the rest of our lives
and it's just that permeating the
discussion of like how many siblings do
you have but you're still thinking about
am I gonna lick your penis or do I have
to like fully reject you and tell you I
don't I'd rather die and maybe I would
rather be like such a weird position
where I'm like hurting you so bad making
you feel so bad honestly you're nailing
it like that it was more of my anxiety a
lot of times on days is like what if I
don't want to yes how badly the best
case scenario is you're like do I want
to yeah or the second night but yeah I
think you would want to bring a friend
that is
uh already with someone so they aren't a
threat but they're like fun and they're
just like wing woman
and then two people who are less
attractive than you okay that's what I
was thinking right she said it's so cold
didn't make eye contact with me rude you
don't show up guys
neither of you are going with me today
bringing three equal hotties could up
your chances of getting the four hottest
boys I gotta bring one Korean friend to
translate
I can't be the only just Whitey not
speaking any not knowing anything
but I wonder if that would translate
over here and how that would work out
like there's so many types of bars
around the world you know what it is
hasn't caught up to like the 28 and over
bars in Australia those I think that's
genius so smart it's so fun to like just
no men will want to go there but the
ones that matter well yeah but like um
you know what I was thinking the reason
why it can't happen here is because our
nasty little pervert American boys would
100 end up raping some of the girls and
then the the bar would be liable do you
know what I mean they'd be like oh we
like set you guys up instead of it just
being like Oh it's a place you guys
could meet to [ __ ] right if you're like
you're coming here to [ __ ] or I guess
you could say find love
I actually take back what I said about
lessons right I kind of want my friends
to be more attractive so that if the
person chooses me I know that they're
like they they up against the odds I
still won like I wanna I don't want to
set it so that I'm not you know I like
the competition yeah I like to win
against your friends because you're dear
friends yeah close the spread yeah I
mean I I don't know in high school I
always I kind of liked being I was
scared of boys so I liked not being the
one that the boys liked but I think now
it just bums me on I have a friend who's
like a model and every time I would like
a boy and I would bring her with us
because she's just fun and like was
never threatening never like she would
she's so pretty that she has developed
techniques to make other girls like her
and comfortable around her because other
girls hate her so much so she's always
like oh I just farted or she'll be like
yeah God I stink or she'll just do this
face where she like tucks up her list
and she's like but she does it right
away as soon as she senses somewhat like
any girl that is a little bit insecure
she does this and then suddenly the girl
likes her I've seen it happen my friend
like she just is so used to girls not
liking her off off the Jump that she has
developed this technique like it
sometimes I'm a runner I'm like you
don't have to be smelly today like it's
okay like just be like it's okay you're
just a pretty girl but then it would
annoy me she would come no makeup
farting smelling her pits and then this
guy that I like she knows I like him and
I'm like you know like meet this guy
that I like I have a crush on I'd bring
her the comedy seller he's like hanging
out with us in the booth and she would
get up to go to the bathroom and I mean
this happens so many times as soon as
she would get up to go they'd go oh my
God she's so good looking holy [ __ ] I
can't even focus oh my [ __ ] god and
it like grow down with me about and then
I go I yeah I know and then it's done I
can't be I can't ever like them ever and
that used to happen with me with my
sister all the time in high school every
time she left the room my friends guys
would just go oh my God how are you
around that all the time
I literally can't leave I legally have
to stay here
um so but yeah that is that's happened a
lot I mean do you you guys it's really
have you ever had that happen where a
guy no I've always sometimes no you guys
are hot I can imagine you know the ones
that get I had no I had a thunderstealer
friend who she didn't even mean to do it
yeah she was just so charismatic so
pretty perfect tits like she just was
like so like sexually like outgoing
everything about her was just so
charming and I would like bring her
around and every guy that had been like
following me around like a puppy dog
with a crush on me that I was like
deciding between I was like should be
Jake or Tom they would come to be like
oh my God they'd be like following
around with like their tongues drooling
and I'm like
thank you but uh it is true like when
they get out of the pods and they pick
their person and then they the other
guys see the other women that they were
got close there's this thing in the
later episodes I'm not giving anything
away really where it's because this
happens every season on that show the
guys see the girl that they would say on
in the real world that's the kind of
girl I would go for and then the girl
that they are with who's like they fell
in love they're like I love you I love
your soul but that's and this one guy is
getting in so much trouble because he's
like well that you know Colleen is a 10
out of 10 you're a nine out of ten but
like she's I'm sorry it's just true
she's hot like and they kind of do that
thing of like but it's am I supposed to
lie to you and it's like the casually
cruel in the name of being honest well
do you watch uh Married at First Sight
no okay they have a guy on it that's
like told his wife that he's not
attracted to her
like after I get married it's like you
just don't I just don't just work on it
and then she got so anxiously attached
to him because he had rejected her so
hard I was like been there [ __ ] he's
like ugly sorry you're ugly he's ugly
he's like a nerd like he's just like
annoying and she's like so cool yeah and
she got these big titties and she's so
like she's just great and she's just
doing everything she can to accommodate
him and it's all because of that initial
like how do you bounce back from this
[ __ ] yeah I I you know I as a serial
dater of agos
um I I let the record play till the very
end and I would never have there was
this one boy I swear I'm not like this
is not trying to be mean at all but I'm
pretty sure he had an extra chromosome
like for certain I was like huh he could
be he could not be but we what we're
gonna talk about him again which guy is
this I thought we were done talking
about it but it's gonna go crazy
no I'm talking
but I liked him so much he he was a
great musician he was a great artist he
was so smart like everything about him
and I remember thinking telling my mom
like I think this person is perfect but
anytime like I roll over when I wake up
in the morning and I see his face like
there's just I'm like [ __ ] like this is
rough but never would I ever imagine
telling somebody like this like oh yeah
you're just I like you but like
typically you're not you know your face
is a little yeah no I had a squint hot
boyfriend like where
he was like he had it all except up
close we're like oh things were too
close together like me he actually
looked a lot like this ugly [ __ ]
finally I've been holding it in you make
me want to throw up because it'll look
hotter
um
um don't we all get ugly eventually so
that's the thing
yeah yeah he could get better looking
maybe men get better looking yeah they
do that old age app remember that that
app that people all the men were
throwing their face in that day and it
really it really ages you in a
convincing way that you're like this is
the truth I remember taking a break on
social media that day because I didn't
want to remind anyone I exist to maybe
throw my face in that I remember like
respecting that day like black lives
matter like I'm taking a break because I
was like out because I'm so scared to
see because it was so real looking those
and I was like if someone does that to
me and I see it I'm gonna like Bird Box
I just had to I can't I will not be I'm
too scared I yeah I just had as bird box
when you spread yours I never even
thought of the movie but I think you
just spread your wings and going only
fans are like dude I'll distract you oh
[ __ ] this looks old too [ __ ]
um it doesn't look like baby birds you
know like that's kind of your [ __ ] does
look like sometimes a baby like the baby
bird skin when they don't have feathers
yet and they're just like and they have
those like black like blue eyes but
their skin is my feathers
I'm so sorry yours will have others
mine there's a beak that's my class
it's packed a few eyes out instead I was
forced recently to
um I I'd hooked up with a guy and he was
we were facing the mirror and he was
fingering me while facing the mirror he
was looking right at me
and I was forced to look straight into
my [ __ ] this whole time and I hadn't
really like wait how okay so if there's
a mirror in front of us he's like sit
we're both sitting like this
yeah I was like I thought he was just
violently pulling your [ __ ]
your legs are weirdly suspended and air
upwards I don't know how but I was very
strong fascinated by what my [ __ ]
looked like I mean I didn't mind it I
was like whoa whoa whoa yeah it was
shocking no I remember my boyfriend's
recorded or someone I've been with
before has recorded um I'm trying to be
more private about my relationship so I
always go this guy I used today oh yeah
yeah you say your ex girl in the past I
have broken up with him before so he was
my ex so my ex uh would videotape like
close-ups or whatever and um and I was
always like that's for him like I don't
want to see that and one time he showed
me and I was like
not
um yeah
better look at yours yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah I look at mine well
I'm like too lazy to like shape my [ __ ]
hair so like I will just it's either
full or bald like that's one or the
other
manscaped thank you so much
um I always get a Little Help from my
sponsor my AAA sponsor but also
um
but yeah so I see it usually like once
every month yeah I see it I check it out
I do a full shave in action though in
action it's a little different it comes
in it comes out of its cage
the bird comes out of the evening it
grabs it brings it back in yeah
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
unfortunately life does not come with a
user manual and for me therapy has been
an indispensable part of feeling better
strengthening my relationships problem
solving all of the above and better help
provides just that it is very accessible
online therapy you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 Hours look we're
working on ourselves we're doing it this
is I think that's like a slug theme here
it's like we're all trying to make
ourselves better like live our best
lives but it's you know things get in
the way you get distracted by you know
ruminating thoughts I have a lot of
trouble kind of you know getting to
sleep but they have a journal app so I
can put in the journal what's going on
so I can talk to my therapist about it
later and it's just good it's like I've
had so many times where I've had a
therapist I don't like and it's seems
like too difficult to find a new
therapist so I'll just stop going right
and it's super normal to feel stuck I
know that when I'm going through a
transition in life and for some of you
that are going through career changes it
is really really easy to focus on the
problem than to try and find Solutions
and this is where a therapist can really
be useful these therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills as the world's
largest therapy service better help us
match three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire to match with a therapist
if things aren't clicking you can easily
switch to a new therapist anytime it
couldn't be simpler no waiting rooms no
traffic no endless searching for the
right therapist learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday that's betterhelp help.com
slash trash Tuesday 30 million women are
impacted by weakening or thinning hair
and if you're one of them there's no
reason to feel any shame around that
that's why today we're talking about
neutriful I'm impacted by Todd's
thinning hair myself
I mean for me right
um when I turn 30 or when I got off my
birth control it was like just clumps of
hair I would just see going down the
drain and I would get so down about it
we should sell that I know we should
sell that on YouTube Jason Momoa we got
something for you but I don't have I
don't have to cry in the shower so much
anymore because since I've been taking
neutrophil and I've been taking
neutrophil for the past two years I'm
telling you guys this isn't a quick fit
yeah this you know just be patient with
the process and I promise you your hair
does grow back I saw some comments
recently that were like does neutrophil
really work or is this a scam I swear on
my life I went into my hairdresser and
she went oh my God it's working I was
like okay yes she's the expert nutriful
has three unique formulas to support
women throughout all stages of life
including postpartum and menopause which
is like really important I hear that's
like a really
an insecure time where you can lose hair
and feel very alone but you're not each
formula is physician formulated using
natural drug free medical grade
ingredients and consistently effective
dosages so you get the most reliable
results and like kalila said
wait in a clinical study 86 percent of
women reported improved hair growth
after six months like it's not a quick
fix it actually treats the root of the
issue and helps you my my personal
experience was around three months I
started to see it but just stick around
for six months I'm telling you it really
happens and I never thought anything
would work for my hair and you can grow
thicker healthier hair and support our
show by going to neutrophone.com and
entering the promo code trash to save 15
off your first month's subscription this
is their best offer anywhere and it is
only available to us customers for a
limited time plus free shipping on every
order get 15 off at neutrophil.com
spelled
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com promo code trash
are you you're so you're getting action
right now no but I have hooked up with
somebody yeah yeah
not not girls yet though she tried not
girls no yeah but just one person and
it's been really fun good yeah really
like really really fun like fun just
keeping it casual like just yeah casual
to a point because I have a hard time
having sex with men that um I there has
to be a mutual like liking or fondness
for each other for me to fully feel
sexual towards them yes
um because you can't just do like one
night never yeah I don't have that in me
I wish I could yeah me neither
you were you're okay with that well I
wasn't okay with I was just blacked out
drunk yeah I wasn't like it didn't feel
yeah because I want more coming up with
emptiness let's just say that yeah I
want Longevity if even if it's a casual
hookup I want it to be something that I
can like have for like a long period of
time maybe even like a situationship
type yes I right now was it George
Kimmel told me this he was like I think
all you can give right now is 80 he's
like if someone is if you can talk
television he marries one Asian he
thinks he's good at math
but he really helped me out because I
was like trying to be like okay well you
know what if like there are feelings
involved but I'm not ready for a
relationship because it's so brand new
off a breakup he was like then you just
have to be upfront like 80 is the max
that you can give the 20 commitment
you're just not there yet I'm like thank
you George Kimmel you [ __ ] nerd it
would be psychotic I mean people do it
that jump from one time I mean we've
seen some on social media that are wild
yeah winners I was like we're like
you're in Gate like you're like whoa
It's like meeting the parents like and
that's like that's a personality
disorder I mean that is a that's
something but also it's like that person
will just like those type of people just
will find like a thriller because they
do it I don't understand where people
because you have to be with that person
all the time all the time they fall so
fast and so hard and yeah I'm the same
way like I feel like you think it's a
narcissistic thing though where they're
seeing how the person feels about them
in the case that we're talking about
suppose to each other through our eyes
no I think it's a deep insecurity of
like needing someone to love you all the
time because you didn't get enough love
from your mother but I also like please
find someone to love you all the time
yeah but find someone who's nice to you
yeah I don't know someone who you're
attracted to because they're mean to you
and not giving enough like that is
something you know I I I've gone for
that in the past too it's it's I think
it's it's so hard not to I don't know I
don't understand people who can like
people that give them enough
right out of the game like I had to work
so hard to get to a place where like
someone giving me what I want and like
loving me unconditionally feels good I
know it just how it does take a while it
does well I was I think I've said this
only before but because you know him
it's funnier Dan St Jermain was like he
was like Annie you always date your mom
then you date your dad then you date
your mom then you date Dad yeah and now
I just date Todd yeah
God but it was like I was like living
out all of my like it's like my dad was
like the funnest coolest meanest right
but that would be mean my mom was like
someone means it was sweet but she was
like not paying attention so what is
that like in a relationship because
you're just so sharp quick Cut Throat
someone and not enough but you're not a
mean person you can be I know you could
yeah you wanted to be
um what is that like when someone's like
mean back to you like what's not back
they're abusive yeah abusive like toxic
really mean I'm not you shut down in
that I'm guessing you don't go no way
they bring the worst and yeah they bring
out the worst also like sexually [ __ ]
yeah like really bad yeah like really
really like wake up in the middle of
night screaming not blowing them enough
no I'm so sorry not good yeah but I'm
not no I'm not mean to guys no yeah
you're really sweet to Todd anytime I'm
on the phone she's not talking to me
she's like like throwing sweet nothings
I love my Todd I call them today on the
way over
because the song came on and I was
called and was like oh that song came on
I made me think about it I love you it's
like I've never been together a while
that's like three years yeah but we have
Frozen embryos so yeah yeah we'll talk
about the ass pimples oh yeah today okay
so the other day I got I joined the I we
drove by an accident and I was like
trying to figure out what the accident
was or what the commotion was they're a
bunch of cops so I downloaded the
citizens app and the next door app to
try to find out nightmares so lame but I
found out that in a neighborhood near
mine it's not my neighborhood there's a
drone someone said there's a drone
that's going through people's windows
like like spying on people and I was
laughing because I was thinking about it
today when Todd was like fully like
spreading my [ __ ] and like popping
zit like inside my ass I was like this
is gonna be wild like I hope it comes
and finds me now wait how does this go
down you like I'm naked right and Todd's
like bring he'll be like bring your ass
over here right oh my God and then so
like but he'll call it
popping pimples I guess yeah he'll like
he'll still go like oh I see one you
know yeah and so I'll go over and it's
like you know it's like is this gonna be
like hot or not and not it really
depends so then he's like he's like you
have to like bend over bend over so it's
like it's me like positioned fully and
like doggies he's like spreading mass
and like popping my zip because the
inside the pimples are always on YouTube
yeah it's like the friction and then so
there was just like full I mean windows
open it just would have been the
funniest time to see the Drone it's just
hovering outside your window and then it
you'd see it just like shake its head
yeah it's like I'm good and then zip
away yeah I know it's like a a guy like
a fat like nasty old guy's just like ew
that's crazy that's sweet I this past
weekend I put a couple um pimple patches
on my butt pimples yeah and but what
happens is that it causes the head to
come out right right so it pushes the
the white head out and
um but it makes it really hard so now
you have a white head in your butt so
this morning I just scraped it off left
a big big pothole bleeding pothole I
don't have a pod yeah
yeah you need you need like a handy Todd
I think I do that's why you got to date
a plumber yeah
I died listen
Todd is available he's on taskrabbit
um yeah
it's good to have someone to pluck and
and
I okay Leisure odd areas but you guys
are super super close yeah I feel as
though the last time I played that game
of being just so like that close with
someone I eventually lost the traction
for them yeah does that ever falter no I
feel like we get more attracted to each
other as we get like yeah we just like
love each other because you get to be
too friend like just Pals popping each
other's zits because I want my I think
for me is I love like my dream like type
of intimacy is that yeah but then I have
this other side where I can easily be
desensitized to someone's like skin on
my skin the closeness of it all so I
have a hard time
um
um separating the two so Todd does not
have yeah
yeah because but that is my dream right
that amount of clothes me too it is like
it's like you guys it's a build the door
open 100 I have a picture of them today
and it's starting yeah he was in his
Timberlands like I was like look at my
Working Man laying his pipe
just taking a [ __ ] I'm always like can I
post this
yeah I want that too I don't have that
in my relationship he's very much like
he doesn't like toilet jokes like he
doesn't like fart jokes like if we're
watching TV and something like poop
related or fart like it's one of those
things where I used to like kind of I
just get awkward for him because I know
he's so uncomfortable well is it because
his family was like too far to you in
front of him or never farty never farty
they are like very like it's but then I
am talk about doing having anal and like
[ __ ] on someone yeah which may or
may not have been him and it's fine like
the first time I remember something like
that kind of happened with him because I
knew his toilet humor thing his aversion
to it was like so strong I thought it's
over but he was so fine with it because
it was you know I was uh it was an
intimate moment he's a good person but I
thought it was going to like he would
never but he's you know it's so weird
that some people we can they can be so
weird about like um sometimes I drop my
retainer on the floor and pick it up and
put it in I don't care about germs if I
don't see them I just don't care even
though and he'll go like oh God and I'm
like but you like
lick my like we like make out and we
like spit on each other like why is this
weird or like sharing drinks or like I
drop something he's like yeah it makes
it grosser now but I know that your
[ __ ] mouth has been on no it's true I
mean no I don't like that like I hate
like I dated a guy who was like
he was like I um have a like hyper
sensitive smell I was like goodbye I
want oh yeah literally forever yes I
know it's the greatest day of my life I
was like dropping so many I threw my eye
like through my [ __ ] [ __ ] wipes in
the trash
like start using to clean my car but
just because he's a super smeller
because I'm a super Smasher but he was
like a judgey guy too he was like a guy
that was never fully letting you in so
it was like he was one of those guys
like looking for an excuse to get out
and yeah it's like gross and I'm not
gonna make it I have a stinky [ __ ] to
get out no okay it's not gonna [ __ ]
happen we're not doing this I'm not
stinky [ __ ] [ __ ] smell when people are
like about to be on their periods and
stuff are you one of those smell
everything what but I'm also obsessed
where am I in my Annie smells really
good all the time yeah she does she does
yeah um you are we're a fair moment you
are
um on your um luteal phase you are one
week a couple days away from your period
I am just are into spot ruin these
underwear body I like saw the spot and I
was like
well I was for me even though I'm like a
super smeller I love people's like if
I'm into a man I love his body odor I'm
really into it even if it's strong I'm
really into I used to pick up my
boyfriend's like dirty underwear and
just fool you sick [ __ ] I loved it I
loved getting in there like yeah it's
not it's I I used to want someone stink
on you that's when it's good to me bang
your brother because there is like a lot
of
um laundry around
it's like laundry day or like [ __ ] it
I'll just grab his too hand me down like
I remember these it's like what you were
saying about
um whether or not her um boyfriend grew
up with a farty or non-party family I
didn't know that that was a thing until
um I met my best friend when we were
teenagers and I remember I never heard
her fart for like the first three years
of her friendship and then one day like
she heard my somebody he fart and she
was like whoa you do that I was like you
can too she's like no I've never farted
loud like in my life oh my God and I was
there when she farted for the first time
loudly and we were all just like oh yeah
oh my God that's what our ass was doing
too and then now she's like the loudest
farter in existence uh yeah cause she's
taking back the night she's gotta yeah
so some families just don't fart around
my mom would let out ass Flappers that
would shake the chandelier
okay it was like an earthquake hit and
it was just like Mom's farts like we're
like oh another one of Mom's farts and
like if one of us farted like that like
my brother like that was like Mom's fart
and then I always have like a memory of
my mom randomly getting mad at my
brother for farting once we were like on
a road trip yeah and she's like Max you
fart you're farting and he's like it's a
bodily function mom and she's like but
I'm seeing you push
and I like never forget on your neck but
you have to like respect the people who
weren't brought up that way because it's
just like it's so crazy to them it's
like and it is it's like polite to not
just like [ __ ] blast [ __ ] ass
smelling people it is life yeah because
it sends particles in the air there are
poop particles let's just say I wake
Todd up a poop
I feel like once you go to sleep and
you're both like on each other's your
phones and they could be asleep that's
when you can like let them go and the
other person doesn't have to call it out
they can hear it but not like it's it's
a safe Zone wait I'm so sorry have you
ever farted in front of a guy and then
they don't say it like you don't ignore
you move yes everything that is my hell
oh I'm just leaving the fart to sit
there and like not like not even like no
I'll just like start kicking the covers
and making like like
to make more noises so that it's like
sounds like it could have been a throat
noise I feel like probably having my my
diarrhea constipation back and forth
sort of ping pong of a yeah of a gastro
system that I think that I like have
just like had to just be like you have
to accept me as I am or we can't do this
because I can't
I can't handle well I think that's why I
don't censor my words why would I censor
my ass right the first three months of
dating I think that's the roughest part
of it all is spending the night at a
boy's house and then holding your farts
in yeah and they always there's always
something you forgot they always come
out to the car when you just like
released
and you're like oh they're knocking on
the window and you're like it's broken
anytime I have these first weekends with
a boy if it's three four days long I
come home with flank pain like the my my
gas has like bubbled up into my lungs so
much or when you breathe it hurts like a
stab and you're like oh
it's so bad I do not miss that I do not
miss beginning and then it turns into
poop farts because you haven't [ __ ] yeah
and by the time you it's like
by the time you do poop it alternates
between gas and poops yes
and you can't tell sometimes you poop
and you're like oh it's gonna be like
just a solid poop with no fart and then
at the end there's like a trombone
you're like I thought this song was over
it's just like oh God my mama don't like
you oh but I muscle with toilet paper I
create a muffler no you just have to
extend your ass I know but sometimes
sometimes my like colon will blur I will
just use I will use Todd's face as a
muffler I don't give I have no respect
for Todd not getting even in the
beginning
no listen Todd's younger than me he's
lucky to be around that's how I thought
I was like you're welcome kid
but it's like no I mean I I think it was
like maybe like two weeks in when it
just I had to stop I remember once my
boyfriend we were watching TV and I I
guess I was just like gassy and I like
burped which I don't even register as
like it's the same as far you know like
not even a gross thing really
now I do but I think at the time I just
like was too comfortable and I just
maybe I'd gone home for Christmas break
and was around my family too much which
is letting burps and farts out yeah
really got you comfortable didn't
realize I was doing it then I tried to
like throw a move on him and I remember
he was just like I'm not I'm sorry like
I'm just you were like burping a lot oh
my and I just I'm not gonna lie like I'm
just not into it right now it's not like
it's it's it'll be fine but like right
now and it was so humiliating but I have
kept that in check so much now and I
need it sometimes you can't you have to
like cancel the night sometimes
depending on what you do right oh yeah
no I had one guy hooked up but then the
first night I hooked up with him I was
just perfect but again it was like sort
of like a like sometimes sometimes I
date guys where I feel like I'm giving
them like my week with Maryland
where I'm like hey you're welcome you're
getting this experience and he was one
of those where I was but it was like
fully like I mean I couldn't help myself
some women do that entire relationship
where they like make up all the time
always look perfect for their husband
they never the husband will never know
the stinky side yeah or like the bads
they're wearing makeup I could pull it
off it's just never it's just I'm not
like I'm not like crass or loud or any
of these reasons like on purpose it's
just the energy energy it would take for
me to like pull back just it's not yeah
I think I go crusty in three weeks yeah
like three weeks is my Max and it's like
because I don't want to break it make it
too like I have like clip in hair like
if a guy's going to my house like I'm
gonna be like all right these gonna come
out like this yeah like they know things
are gonna change yeah the makeup thing
I've gotten over like in the beginning
putting on makeup before they woke up
like you know just just touching
yourself up but yeah now I I think I
show that side right away because that
is never habitable but farts I feel like
I'm a mouth breather so it's like I'm
gonna be like waking them up
you know what I mean so I've always
wanted my boyfriend to take a picture of
me sleeping just because I think it's
sweet when you're like you just admire
you just watch someone sleep and when
they're like she looks so Angelic I'm
gonna take a picture because he sleeps
like a little like he seriously like has
a slight smile and his lips will be
close and he literally puts his hands
like this he looks like and I'm always
like he's so beautiful he's never one
sick because I look my face fall Andrew
my opener is set on planes my face Falls
like a quarter inch like all the skin
yeah like I it's so disgusting no I say
I look like my parents have to make like
a really tough decision
like the mass or the greatest thing
that's ever happened to me I put eye
mask on mouth mask my mouth my mask is
always down to here I look like
everybody yeah remember that though the
years of Terry shivo oh yeah when we
just like every day we were checking in
on whether or not she was gonna depart
or stay hoping she didn't get pregnant
we're like we can't do it oh my God oh
my God
well you know that happened to who was
it
well there is a movie about this
happened called um it was a real story
no no when the there's like just a
paralyzed woman that all of a coma woman
who's all of a sudden pregnant oh my God
oh my God who did this it does not
surprise me one bit listen I don't mind
playing that like that's a good role
play for me
yeah we can do it but real life
what Jessabelle is the movie where that
happens Jezebel yeah
yeah oh well don't get Jessica
the most wonderful time of year is also
the most hectic especially if you have
an online store yes Esther
you gotta use ship station all the time
yeah I I sell my underwear I sell my
your socks I sell my
um my nipple hair I saw your nipple hair
sometimes I sell my Q-tips and I don't
even tell you which hole I put more
important it's a surprise if you're
still using the default shipping option
to run your online store chances are
you're putting up with a lot of
unnecessary Hassle and limiting your
potential growth shipstation works with
all of your favorite places to sell
online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and more over 130 000 companies
have grown their e-commerce businesses
with shipstation and 98 of companies
that stick with ship station for a year
become customers for life life it's a
good product this holiday season give
yourself the gift of stress-free holiday
shipping use promo code trash Tuesday
today at shipstation.com to sign up for
your free 6ca trial that's
shipstation.com promo code trash Tuesday
okay here's what I love about manscaped
as a like a holiday gift for your guy or
for whoever
it does it's like it is a little bit of
like okay you need to do some grooming
right but it is there's a sexual
undertone to it right it's a call to
action yeah it is and it's for it's a
call to get action yes it's interactive
it's cute it's funny it's kind of a very
ideal gift it's a way to like get him to
be more clean and trim but like cute but
also it's like we don't really care
about you having hair we just need to
know that you're thinking about us and
sometimes that means taking your little
trimmer in the shower
um using the LED light for extreme
accuracies and you know making us happy
that way and inside the performance
package 4.0 you'll find the signature
lawnmower 4.0 this electric trimmer has
propriety Advanced Skin safe technology
and it's also waterproof so you can use
it in the shower and it's like a gift to
yourself with less mess the manscape
performance package 4.0 also includes
the crop preserver and the crop reviver
an anti-chafing ball deodorant moisture
Riser and toner keep his North Pole
feeling and smelling fresh and be
careful when you put your tongue on and
you don't want it to get stuck
Annie I feel like if I was someone like
you like you have brothers you have your
dad like you're so many men in your life
like you're someone who would be like oh
so easy just get everyone man I thought
you were gonna go I feel like you're
someone with a huge Bush I don't know
why I thought you were gonna like come
from yeah no everyone's getting it they
call me Santa balls
okay that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use code trash Tuesday
get your man a gift you'll both enjoy
the gift of manscape his jingle balls
will thank you do you think if you give
it to your dad your mom will be like
thanks girl I think my mom will have to
do she cuts his hair already she'll
probably have to be the one doing it
they're codependent
there's some times when a boy
um is either just a little too ripe oh
yeah and you're but you can be cute
about it she's like oh we're gonna
shower I'm gonna like scrub you down you
stinky boy yes yeah hold your balls
because I'm getting in there can you
hold them up
get the Windex
yeah but there is a point it's like I
like your Bo I like your Bo okay like
we've gone over yeah yeah there's the
line here
yeah
I'm trying to like remember like uh
where I'm like fail there's this whole
thing of like be yourself but then
there's in like I feel this conflict as
a woman of like be yourself lizzo like
love yourself no matter what you are and
then this other thing of like but do all
of the micro needling do the cool
sculpting do the extensions and like but
that's also yourself and I'm like but
but it's also like not myself and but if
you want to do it do it and if you don't
want to do it don't do it but I'm like
but I'm all I only would want to do it
if you want me to do it and I want you
to is is the real me wanting people to
like me more so should I do it like do
you ever have that conflict you don't
seem to you just do whatever the [ __ ] I
do whatever the I you know what my like
hack is that
I am I just like tell the truth so it's
like whatever I do I'm gonna tell
everyone so I don't feel like there's no
secret I'm not like hiding anything like
I think it's funny if my track show I
think it's like my eyelash falls off I'm
like bonus like I like that my ab my
fake abs look fake I like you know like
I always make my fake tits look like
really fake like I think it's funny to
like be playing on it but then also the
the plus side is is it looks cute yeah
it's like when you squint you go are
those abs yeah but I know what you mean
it's almost like even even people will
admit to micro needling or getting
lasers done but not to fillers or yeah
to other parts of it because it's that's
a more I don't know like a more uh you
know a real yeah shameful cosmetic
procedure but it's like it's all the
same yeah it also doesn't like matter or
lie about their highlights like it used
to be shameful to like oh no this is the
hair I was born with like they used to
be shamed it was almost like the way a
filler is now like it's kind of
acceptable but a lot of people still lie
about it yeah now highlights no one
hides it feels like the same uh no you'd
be a psycho like if you did that like
it'd be like you're [ __ ] crazy
but I feel like just the farting and
that with me is the same thing I'm not
like I am like just so
like you know I'm just so honest and
it's like it's too hard for me to not be
it's like almost like Aspergers
like where it's like I just fart and
stuff because it's like I just it's too
hard for me to upkeep the like lies of
it all but God loves that about you it
feels closer with you guys for me I have
to basically put it up front for
somebody I'd burping does gross me out I
don't want a dude like if you're in the
bathroom and I hear a couple farts here
and there but like I I've been with
someone who was just too a little too
free with it and it took away the Sexual
Energy between us and that's just the me
thing yeah and I'm not saying it's it's
a correct thing for everybody but I know
that it zaps it out of me and so I don't
want to partake in your little farts
fast
um to kind of preserve my sexual
feelings for you and them respecting
that boundary is like a turn on like it
means like my boyfriend doesn't like
fart stuff I would love if he did but he
doesn't yeah and I just respect that
that grosses him out and you can't help
it it's just a part of his fiber and who
he's not doing it to like keep you down
yeah
you burped and you're a bad girl I feel
like that turned me on
I'm like he's talking to herself right
now I think he needs to be alone can we
get a divider
I used to when I worked with special
needs kids or kids with special needs
that we would like there was always like
an orientation before each summer it was
a summer camp that we'd in every
orientation you'd have to talk about
um self-stimulation and so we would
because the kids just start jerking off
yeah and because it was like it was like
kids up to like I thought you were like
teaching how to do it yeah we're showing
them yeah
um it was like sit sit Indian style
rest your balls on your heels no um but
so um wheel your wheelchair over here no
but we were like you know we had like
changing stations for them with their
the mats yeah and then so like the rule
protocol was when they started jerking
off you can't stop them because it's
like they're right they don't realize
they're doing something wrong it's like
so you would just take like the mat that
you change them on and just like
create their accounts
my kids were higher functioning and they
weren't they weren't the jerk off ones
so I didn't have to do when did you guys
start jerking off
uh well I was uh I was Catholic so very
early yeah that's suppressed yeah yeah
no I I had a lot of Shame around
masturbation when I was younger
um even around sex I think um I it
wasn't until I was much older that I was
like oh I can do this every day and I
should be doing this every day yeah as a
teenager no I was like I did it but when
I did I was like what did I do like how
shameful I couldn't look at myself in
the mirror I think that is why Annie you
were talking about female Comics
everyone thinks all we do is talk about
sex yeah you know and no all Comics do
you just watch if you just blindly watch
all Comics are only talking about sex
it's good though to show the general
public what we get yeah met with because
they don't know well I can't go down
that road anymore I've done it I usually
one of my period it's like I can't
respond to these people it's like I
create accounts to defend myself but
again I get mad I get I do like it does
like the women aren't funny it's like
I'm like you're trash like get away from
me that pisses me off and then the all
women talk about his sex it's like all
guys are talking about jerking off their
dicks [ __ ] like the ones that aren't
are like predators that are trying to
[ __ ] the audience yes pretend that's not
what they're doing they're like oh I
don't want to remind them because I'm
like they keep their kids shows kid
friendly so that they can [ __ ] kids yes
exactly
for a reason but I do feel like it's
like it come I talk about sex so much
I'm so comfortable with it and you
because I just had the same thought that
I'm sure people have with me when I say
that I didn't have sex I was 21. I'm
scared of it very shame but like you the
person that's so comfortable with sex
like you seem so comfortable talking
about sex but that's so ironic that it
was something that you weren't
comfortable with but of course that
makes sense because now that you once
you learn you like oh wait this whole
time I was like ashamed of this thing
that's totally like fine I don't want to
talk about it a lot so that someone out
there that might be ashamed as you were
and living in this like
prison of like feeling just like I don't
know what's what it is and you just want
to like get all the information out
there it's like it's like with um they
say like what is it guys think about sex
every 10 seconds but we're not supposed
to [ __ ] talk about the thing ever
thinking about until it's like that's
something that's so annoying it's like
but guy but April had like one of her
responses was like well guys always talk
about this this and this and it's like
no no no they talk about sex yes they do
specifically but you guys infantilize us
and you look at us like we're objects or
we're not allowed to have like thoughts
so all you're thinking about your only
thing about sex so then that's what you
hear like I've done jokes that have
nothing to do with sex and they'll write
that under my thing I'm like that's not
sex yep life that's sex then everything
in life is sex you know don't watch
Annie's special with your kids it's like
why would you be watching a comedy
special with your kids yeah get Grandma
out of the room before you see Annie
It's like by the way grandmas are my
[ __ ] boys yeah yeah they're it's like
well someone was saying this to me I
can't remember who it was it was like
it was someone that reminds me of you
was like Carlos like but they were like
the grandmothers of now are not the
grandmothers of when we first started
now are just like Grandma like the the
older the old people now are like cool
as [ __ ] yes they're like dirty [ __ ]
they are like what my shows are so old
my dad came to one show and was like
your audience is old and I'm like
I always meet people at my parents age
I'm like you're my fan like yeah my
parents get so proud but yeah you're
right it's not when we say grandparents
we're like those people are like gone
the ones that are like that are like the
greatest Generation they're done
they're gone and it's just it's fun it's
like and I always feel like I'm like
judging if I see like an audience member
that's older and I'm like
I always am wrong they're always wrong
because I'll even get like a group that
I I want to do crowd work I found out
they all met at church they're all still
laughing and all the books yes and my
stepdad is 75 and he watches this show
oh and every time every week he texts us
and he's just like that was just so
entertaining sweetie oh you know it's
still like these 75 year old like I
can't handle already teacher he can
absolutely they can all handle well I
keep calling my family with those fake
boobs on yeah
and family is a different story well my
nieces are like my baby niece is like
who's she's six now she's like
she's like let me see the neeps let me
see the neebs and then my my brother and
sister like do not they look too real
I'm like I always like flash nipple and
she's just like laughing so hard it just
cracks them up but it is weird because
they look so real they look so real it's
crazy the comedy started and I was wild
I'm so glad I don't have big boobs I I
know exactly why you got your tits taken
out wait tell me what did you experience
it's a different I'm so so happy this is
what I was given because they're so real
you can see what how guys
when you got yours taken out did you see
the pen so the the upside was
um obviously this was a time when you
know I was still drinking doing that so
it's like the male attention is heavy
but it's the wrong kind of male
attention it's not the male attention
that I seek and usually if I go to a bar
and if I hit it off with somebody there
is something more than just like usually
I have to like find my way or like I
usually there's a conversation that
Sparks it all and they're like oh I like
that girl because she said this one
thing about this one no it was like just
my tits it was my tits it's like wearing
glasses it's like they go glasses girl
you're like tits girl um it was crazy
though like Jeff died I didn't even
realize he hasn't spoken to me in three
years until I was wearing those tits he
was like I know they're fake but it
still works he was like open doors right
people were like rolling out a red
carpet like
but it made me like so appreciative of
the amount of attention I get without
tits I was like wow this feels like real
yeah yeah I feel like awesome I feel
really uncomfortable when I have
cleavage because I feel like it's
creating and this is so me
kind of uh I'm embarrassed to say this I
feel bad creating a just like creating
something that men have to like fight to
look at it's a disturbance like I feel
bad for them that they are like being
drawn to it and they can't it's I guess
it's full restraint you're surrounded by
people that aren't being themselves that
aren't being open yes like I was talking
to like a couple of my married friends
it was like Benji and um and uh Ryan
O'Neal yeah she got married oh my God
that's so weird thank you for not
inviting me seriously I'm like annoyed I
didn't get to reject it I would have
said no but no but I was like talking to
them and and at the comedies the other
night with it and I was like going as a
nip slip so I had like the nip out and
I was like you can look at it like this
isn't cheating but like how is it it's
like so
because they're so real looking everyone
was like can I grab them I was like
motorboating Joe URL the comic with
cerebral palsy
it was like really
um it was just it was but you're right
it's like it was like
um
yeah like throwing like a grenade and
being like you can't look at the
explosion even even for women like I
know I can't if someone had their
cleavages out I'm looking me too
straight into it probably longer than
the man like I'm really looking yeah
definitely well when did you get yours
not out when did you get them in
28 and what made you get them
um my sister had just gotten them at
that time I was
um I had the last person that I dated
before that was a Spanish footballer and
um he loved girls with boobs yeah and um
so when that relationship ended and I
started and that whole summer I decided
that I was just gonna get them this is
somehow this was going to be my hot girl
season and then I started dating Bobby
and I remember I had already made my
appointment to get my boobs done and he
was like I will pay you the exact amount
of money you're about to pay to not get
them done
um but in my head let's split the
difference I only get one and I I
remember I was like he doesn't mean that
he's a guy like he's just saying that to
be this like sweet guy who but turns out
he really does like
um small breasts so I got them anyway
yeah as soon as I woke up I I I cried
right into my double door like I hate
these I hate these I hate the way my
body looks with this you never enjoyed
them I think I I took him out at a year
and a half for under two years after oh
my God yeah wow it was like they were in
there fast like I know that you're gonna
have to get them redone again it's
probably so daunting to know you have to
go through it again oh yeah if it wants
you're just like it's smoke at some
point maintenance like buying a house
but also my body just fully rejected it
I started feeling all of these weird
symptoms I didn't feel good in my body
and I generally I I
all the clothes that I loved being in I
could no longer wear I had to change my
entire wardrobe and I wasn't just like
cool tomboy anymore I usually like baggy
shirts like I just had a look to me that
I could no longer yeah be so what your
idea of what you thought it would be was
there anything that you invented in
yourself wearing or like doing in that
kind of like bikinis or anything did you
take advantage of that at all yes I did
so like I I remember feeling like oh I
don't ever have to wear a bra so I never
wore a bra that was they're so tight
they were just if I could just wear
white my nipples out you know so I had
that freedom that's I think what I was
chasing but I remember when I took my
implants out and I my boobs were back to
normal and soft and a little bit you
know saggier I liked the look better
yeah without a bra they were up here
they were tight they were high and tight
I hated them um I look back at pictures
now and I'm like that is not me like
that is not me recovery was that brutal
yeah I feel like we just don't even when
when women get their faces done or um
liposuction or these or get your tits on
they they're so ashamed of doing it I
mean some some of them are like before
and after and it just seems like instant
but that the recovery is so brutal right
like just the blood and the pain and
like having to walk around and like
especially women getting their faces
done they don't talk to anyone about it
I've had friends do it and they I just
had like vocal cord surgery I need and
there was no blood it was you know not
painful but I needed so much support
around me to get through that when did
you have a
um two months ago how hard was it to not
talk it was awesome I mean oh you liked
it I would never be able to do it it was
so hard were you like that like the dad
and Legends of the Fall where you had
like a Anthony Hopkins
this is why we're like pretty sure she's
gonna end up dating Brad Pitt but it's
fine oh my God yes we are pretty sure
it's gonna happen so much I don't want
to brag but everything I said comes true
don't give me another alcoholic no you
don't know I don't think he drinks
anymore I would wish that for you for
like a couple like no just so I can be
right yeah yeah
it's not your that's not your husband
right right right but I feel like just
yeah a lot of people have go through
these surgeries and they don't they go
through it alone because they're so
Shane and they can't be like if I have a
facelift which I'm going to have at some
point I'm going to be like honest about
it like yeah do you know there's no what
why create content about the recovery
but I think that we I wouldn't have
known did you know how was it that
painful or am I exaggerating like did
you know the recovery was going to be
what it was were you prepared for it um
pain yeah no I think that everyone is
like oh yeah you can you can get back to
work in two days is it what they tell
you right well you knew from your sister
probably what it was going to be like
right or did you guys do it two days
apart no my recovery was rough like my
my blood pressure dropped a couple times
like I just didn't my body didn't take
to it like uh maybe other people did you
regret it right away were you like [ __ ]
yeah yeah immediately I was like
something's not right and especially
with Bobby being like don't do it like
you had someone that was like they're
telling you not to and then can you
imagine getting like tits is one thing
and like regretting that that's gotta
like you crying into them such like a
scene at least you could get them
removed and it could go back to normal
but like doing something to your face
and then waking up and being like no
like that's why the filler knows jobs
I'm like ladies filler nose jobs also
like yes filters on look at my nose yes
filters on Tick Tock baby I think it's
very brave Contour [ __ ] stuff and I
feel like we shame a lot of women for
getting work done but sometimes I'm like
that girl took a [ __ ] it is
and people go what did Meg Ryan do to
her face why which she didn't want to
look like that she she got some bad
advice no one told her no it went too
far like she's just trying to she's
trying to look like she did and sleep is
in Seattle she's trying to get that back
don't but I think men especially oh and
especially when they find out their
girlfriends want to get stuff done they
go no because they think of they see
those bad plastic surgeries and go don't
do this and it's like that woman didn't
want to look like that we're all trying
to stay young for you like better if you
just don't say anything they're gonna be
like oh my girls
but they start to get so threatened
because they think you're trying to get
hotter for someone else it's like it's
not about that I want to be perceived as
hot but it's not to [ __ ] other people I
just want people to be like nicer to me
well the culture looks like of younger
girls now is like all the like
preemptive or whatever oh yeah it's um
preventative preventative yeah talks and
stuff so it's like everybody looks like
but if you were 70 when they're 70s the
new 20s yeah it's like who cares it's
like it's just like it's just like the
look now like I don't think it looks
better or like it's just like it's a lie
because if you look at pictures of
yourself when you're 11 and 12 we've
always had these Rings yeah I've never
not had these like all of my younger
I've oh yes always have had this yeah I
know it's like you have people telling
you that oh no it's preventative take
these out and I'm like wait no they're
meant to be there they've been there
since you were a child I'm just like
where what's taking up the slack like if
we shaved our heads like all the girls
with botox just have like wrinkles I
always think about my nose if I my nose
sticking down it's like a pencil
somewhere my face like it's pulling the
skin up if I do this it will drop like I
want to build up but your face your face
has to have like a certain I always feel
like giving up like the same amount of
face meat right so like when you see oh
that's like or a guy like I can I see
nose jobs because my one of my brothers
had a oh I see them I can see them is
that like my other proportions out is
that like my collapsed nasal valve yes
oh oops
because they're always tiny and they
have a little Boop yeah they do like uh
like there's like a ski slope situation
but which it looks cute but it's like
you got to put that meat somewhere else
you gotta go in the chin the cheek
somewhere that's interesting I feel like
the same amount like you can just move
it to different areas
your skin has gotten the reason that
you're getting wrinkles is because your
skin is getting looser okay so then when
you fill it's it's just you your face
gets big because it's just filling out
the more skin so that's why women's
faces just get huge with fillers so you
gotta you gotta watch it but I I mean I
I do follow and stuff I got like like
right when I smile there's like a dent
here I can't I saw it on the tiger belly
video and I'm like I can't deal with it
there's a dent but I think everyone
eventually gets that you get that
natural or not but like it's I need to
get it like filled in but when they go
in and they fill it that's I think it's
because you and I like you're cheeky I'm
cheeky as well so we get this little
like it's yeah dimple right here yes
yeah but it's I don't know it's you feel
I feel great whenever I get stuff in my
face I'm like you're so brave you took a
shot and it like worked out and then a
couple days later I'm like oh why did
you do that do you notice like if
someone else has like a dent or
something oh I I know everyone and what
they've done
you've had stuff done but you are just
like a gorgeous person I would think if
I didn't know you and I just saw you I
would think you've had cheek filler but
not a lot and I think you'd have a maybe
a chin job like a chin like a chin
sharpening I actually have like a scar
from my my scooter accident have you
ever had any feel or anything wow
because she made a good point because
she has um she doesn't make a lot of big
facial expressions
yeah you are kind of
like you are you're like sociopath
everyone no you're like you're a mean
dollar but I'm like no I literally have
like something yeah yeah I just I have a
resting face yeah the resting my dad
called me a [ __ ] face
my dad was mean okay he's very nice now
yeah
Kim Kardashian never like does not smile
and I remember hanging out with a
Jennifer Lawrence once and she like was
like stop stop making me laugh like and
holding her face so that it wouldn't oh
my God see I don't want to live like
that I don't wanna I had well you look
great on camera that's all that matters
yeah right yeah thanks for adding one no
but I mean no no I'm just saying like
like you are in this like world like
you're maybe not like the movie star
status yet but you're like you're like
hosting these Netflix shows and stuff
and you're like on and you look great so
it's like isn't is that telegenic I'm
not photogenic but I'm telegenic I mean
I think you're photogenic too but I'm
just saying like you know what I mean
where it's like
like she seems so worried like we were
talking about to soci bacon about how
she was in smile and she's like her the
whole movie's her face yes and she's
like before I got Botox but I'm like no
because she's being an actress like if
she had Botox it would have been weird
yeah and she screamed I mean the whole
part is like it's a close-up of her face
screaming yeah so it is just like what's
the what's the move
um hey my friend oh my friend uh told me
that she heard somewhere or maybe she
just noticed that great actresses
especially Jennifer Lawrence speaking of
never blink in scenes and that's that's
how to be a good actress is that you
just never blank because blinking just
kind of makes you look nervous and like
you're out of your element you're like
what's my next I'm gonna start trying
that that's why I can never be an
actress like I have excessive blinking
you do yeah yeah yeah when I even if
there's like a tiny thought in my head
my eyes start to go like this oh yeah
that's how I know you're thinking [ __ ]
about us oh she's blinking again
about me what do they call me like
somebody like somebody wrote something
they were like they called me like blink
183 or something
the number of times
84. 84 1984 blink 184. it was so funny
when I read it like they're so right
like his hot dogs
um blinker so I really really I'm always
in awe with people like who can just
maintain I also am not great with eye
contact like I have to reset reset yeah
well do you say um do you say filler
words a lot I say like all the time all
the time and I'm done trying to not do
it I'm I think it's a way to dismiss
women again I think it's just a way all
they say are like it's just a thing that
you hear women well here's the thing the
reason why saying like and um is a
negative thing is because you're not
sounding like concise and to the point
but you guys aren't listening to us
anyway so who cares
it's and it's for people we I talk fast
and if I talk fast I gotta put in likes
because I'm not you know no you and I
are I'm not good at doing stand-up like
this and
taking my time with a punch like I have
so much respect and also disdain for
comedians who just don't care about
getting laughs they can just take a
really long time to get to a punchline
and tell a story and take someone
through
a moment and we know exactly who you're
talking about really oh I don't even
know who I'm talking about I can just
think there's just so many people who
just go did you do like a half smile
there no I swear I don't have anyone in
mind but I think it's most comedians I
mean it's even Chappelle I mean
Chappelle has a right to do whatever the
[ __ ] he wants at this point well show
Politics the pauseberg so he could slap
the mic on his knee yeah but I'll do it
I'm not above a knee slap I'll do it do
it because I I'm and I'm I really wish I
could take more time on stage because I
think audiences will go for with you if
you're captivating enough I mean you
know you want to go your own speed I
need to like do you feel like you're
like performing like I'm going up like
as myself saying things yeah that's like
people that are like doing a a show
which a lot of people are but it's like
you're doing a show like I would be so
unhappy doing a show of just doing it
the same way or you'll every time and
always getting a little bit
yeah
oh everything made me laugh like I said
it for the first time when I've said it
literally like every Broadway shows it's
super hurts I don't like rehearsed I
remember when I first started comedy so
I started like hanging out with a
specific group of people and one of the
guys I hung out with he was like I've
been in comedy maybe four years when I
started and I was I went to two shows on
a row and I couldn't believe it when I
saw him go like what's that word two
times in a row and I was like what is
what did you do why are you doing that
and he was like well you know it gives
the audience like it makes them feel
like you're coming up with it right then
which is like I guess brilliant in a way
right yes and it did work he did like
kill but I'm like you don't do comedy
anymore because you probably wanted to
die doing that every day yeah I wanted
to enter into any kind of like
and like I had this bit about you know
guys saying that like dating younger
women and being like well she has an old
soul and I really when I wrote it it was
I was like furious at all older men
saying this and so it like I wrote it
with a lot of anger then I went through
a stage where I was just like I don't
care these let people be with who they
want but when I did my special I like
something happened that day earlier with
like a guy older guy that with a younger
girl that I just I don't even know what
it was but it enraged me and I was able
to access that I didn't have to fake it
that night on stage and it felt so good
and then it got I was even more mad
about it but it is hard when you write a
bit that is like really written in like
anger and then you kind of get you
worked through it yeah you're like
lame to be mad about this now I have a
question so I remember hearing I
remember where it was but someone had
asked you like they're like oh you're
coming back to this place is it going to
be the same set or whatever like what's
this and you were like I it's gonna be
you're like I'm pulling from several
hours of Comedy like yeah it was
something does that do you remember
saying that I mean it could be like well
yeah me too I mean yeah yeah but like I
would when do you start when you're
gonna do a special because I have to do
a special soon it's like when you do a
special how far ahead of time are you
going like unlocking these jokes so
embarrassing and I mean honestly it
varies but because I want to die it's so
much fun when you when you I don't have
the date yet well when you get the date
I'd say like I lock I would lock mine
like I didn't lock it minutes before and
then change it for the second show
because I can't I can't like survive and
uh just like saying the same it sucks I
it's not fun are you like a month before
you start like maybe thinking about what
works and then dropping the things that
you're like it's a c it's not gonna
become an A in this amount of time stop
fooling yourself that this joke that's
been a c for five years is gonna finally
find it yeah and then you start just
doing all the a stuff even though you're
bored of it or a b and then you make a
set list like I don't know like a week
before and then I just run it a ton and
I have like an iPad on stage and I just
follow it to it to type it out and then
have friends come see it and then help
tag it out and then you'll come up with
news and then it'll then it feels fresh
because you have like new stuff because
I just cannot going on the road it's
like people can come see me you can stay
the whole weekend you're not gonna
you're not gonna see the same set yes
same for me it's going to be totally
wild you have I have no clue what's
happening I don't know what I'm gonna
say sometimes I am going to laugh at my
own jokes because I'm like oh that was
fun yes what just came out I laugh at my
own joke it is genuine yeah I'm really
cracking myself up here yes and that's
what I like about watching you too it's
like it's just there's no performative
and I know that a lot of people do like
that in their comedy they want to go see
a show they like they'll find it to have
a performative quality but I also think
that they don't know that it's
performative I think that person is
tricking them and I want people to be
better
purveyors of comet is that the right
word like I want people to be a little
bit more Savvy when it comes to Comedy
and not get tricked by the the the fake
laughing at your own joke the the thing
of like what's that word the what was it
it was on the tip of my tongue this
happened this morning those kind of
things like tips of your tongue why were
we talking about the tip of the tongue
yeah you're like oh God or or flubbing
like I've done we've all done this where
you flub a joke and then you in the
moment you make like a funny joke off of
that and you're like oh I'm gonna have
to recreate that moment if I do that I
will make it very obvious that that's it
will be so rehearsed looking that I feel
like I I hope the audience knows that
that is not me faking it but I just want
people to be more Savvy but I think
your shows is a sad but don't you feel
like but don't you feel like too when
you're like feeling like sometimes I
just would go let everyone do everything
they want to do I know you because last
week we were talking about how did you
see the article that was like making it
was like talking [ __ ] about all the guys
doing talk about their kids and comedy
no it's like let them talk about their
[ __ ] kids
then I'm like what was their point about
it like that it's like two Earnest or
something like you don't decide like
they have an Earnest moment who cares I
like your thing of like no no you saying
just let them do like who can don't
police anyone's standing because it is
like it's always like a time I'll be
honest I get jealous of performative
Comedy because I can't do it it's too
hard it's too much work to come up with
a script and like those are people that
sit down and memorize lines and work and
then listen to their set afterwards and
I'm jealous I've taped every sub and so
I'm shaming it so that I don't have to
do it Nikki do you ever feel like do you
because I feel like because I have 80d
it's like I always have this sort of
like the grass is greener or like
tomorrow I'll figure this out yeah so I
always I'm like maybe there's gonna be a
time where I figure out just sitting
down and writing I know and not just be
like and then like oh [ __ ] that worked
okay yeah I I said I have taped every
single set and never listened to a
single one I have thousands of hours on
my phone uh say hard drives never will
listen I always tell my parents like if
I die put out that stuff like have
someone go through it and put that out
as like the Lost Tapes how sad would it
be if it's just all the same set you
realize like you really have only been
doing the same set like if you go to
like a set from 2012 and you're like oh
God [ __ ] am I still doing that how'd
that happen I wouldn't be surprised yeah
um sorry this is boring I wasn't like
saying no no no it's fine no you got
finally escaped oh my God you escaped
got away from Escape people talking
about this we are when I look at Olivia
Munn I'm like how did you get roped into
this like Olivia you're on the road like
you're Olivia Munn run what are you
doing I forbid my openers from talking
to me about stand up on the phone like I
hate talking about stand up so much and
it's it doesn't seem like it from this
conversation but I hate going over a set
and being like I think this really
worked what about this tag like I male
Comics I think really enjoy doing well
that remember we were talking about I
was I was talking to the comics where
I'm like I there's so many of my comic
friends I just saw from New York that I
haven't seen in a while and it's like
it's been so long since I saw them that
I'm like what do we talk about like I
was like I don't even know what like you
like I don't even know how to like
please you like what compliment do you
want to hear like in L.A it's like nice
shoes did we all just want to [ __ ] each
other yeah well we all just like we've
never heard anything now we're like
married and like not into each other yes
everyone got fat it's like yeah but it's
but then I realized what the New York
male Comics one is they want you to go
like they really like when you use that
word instead of that word yes please do
the timing and he went it was really on
Rhythm like I can't yes I found it one
of those I could give you one I just
I've I've barred like my my friend
Andrew who would open for me and I do a
podcast with he knows like don't be like
did you did you think I should do this
line or like I just go why would you ask
like do you think I watched your set and
he knows that I don't either I'm like if
you asked me to watch your set I'll
watch one minute of it you know and this
could be you're doing a whole hour I I
hate and when people go I'm sorry other
Comics I'm sorry I haven't seen your
special I'm like ew why would you watch
it like you're a cop no offense like
okay I do I'm just getting back into
watching people stand up and it is good
to do because you realize
like you realize how important how good
the art form is and I forget because I
think I was jaded for a while but you
are like man this is actually like I get
it now it's weird but there are people
who
at and I heard the thing of like would
you ever listen to a musician that's
like I don't listen to music it'd be
like ew no I would never so that kind of
sounds like Bobby he never watches um
comedies yeah like any funny movie so
everything he watches is very dark so
horror is his number one genre that or
like super like sci-fi did he see
terrifier too yeah no I don't think so
we were supposed to watch Barbarian
you like core stuff I like Gore really
like slicy slices
but no rom-coms nothing where everyone
Jake Gyllenhaal was like a half man and
his appendix were coming and what's that
one in the Train movie what was that
train movie and at the end he was just
like source code he was just like he was
just like you could see his intestines
he looked like a genie
of um laziness apparently being a myth
to call someone lazy is not a thing that
um what what are they saying about it
um that it's actually very detrimental
to call someone lazy it's usually it's
like a human made it's a it's a it's a
our jokes aren't lazy lazy remember that
laziness is a puritanical myth based on
the sin of idleness and used to oppress
people into forced labor
you either need rest more inspiration or
are denying yourself something you want
because a part of you feels like you
don't deserve it well she seems like she
was a little lazy with that brush huh
that's your hair [ __ ] huh look home
come on we're looking at you laziness is
like it's it's the thing of um no one's
ever deemed themselves lazy or been
called lazy and felt inspired to do
something about it it always makes you
more lazy it makes you go into shame
like what I always think about when I
was kind of doing eating disorder
recovery and they were talking about
binge eating like if you go on a binge
and let's say it gets out of control and
you kind of stop and you go oh I'm such
a piece of [ __ ] I ate like you know 20
cookies when I only wanted one the shame
that you feel about those 20 cookies is
gonna make you eat the rest of the bag
of cookies whereas if you just go woof
yikes looks like I needed 20 cookies I'm
going through something emotionally you
could stop at the 20 cookies right so
like I think the laziness thing when I
call myself lazy it's it's cutting it's
like to hurt me more right it's never
gonna be calling someone's lazy has
never gotten anything we have a
flashback to earlier
just like the devils like remember this
yeah oh my God I want to play with them
so much but I truly don't think if you
think about it
excellent do you remember of course
Babcock is like a number one devil
Sticker song what is a devil stick
I don't know
batons and then there
fore and you can throw a dreadlock hair
when when yeah there you go I've never
seen this in my life it's like you're
having your own like dirty dancing it's
so fun oh that seems fun it was it was
fun no Camp I was always like oh my God
he's such a good devil sticker yeah
but Ron Babcock's still good at it it's
like he was so lazy like do you feel
like like because I feel like I always
call myself blazing people go you're the
least lazy person I go you don't know
you don't know that it looks like I'm
doing a lot from like my tours and
podcasts but that's I'm pretty sure I
have some form of this autonomia like
like
they call it pots like postural
orthostatic like
hypotension my blood pressure drops a
lot of words for me to but it's called
pots and it's basically I feel chronic
fatigue and I have to fight it every day
every time I work out it's like this
battle in my head and I've always shamed
myself for being like why don't I want
to just get up is that why they call
marijuana pots
um I think I have some milder version of
it and um how do you get through how do
you motivate yourself to work out when
you are shoes is it mental you know she
has a habit of it no way can I say
pretty bad though no but you okay so in
your blood because she was raised as an
athlete and she was like the the meal
ticket for the family they're like swim
[ __ ] swim so this is just me imagining
I didn't know you were swimmer yeah
College in through college wow girl she
was like sorry about Champion that is a
200 meter butter I mean just in high
school really yes I love I miss it I
started to get a butterfly and then I
got in a car accident I'll get you back
there butterfly was like I was like once
I started to get the Rhythm about it
that's my party trick you can bust as an
adult doing butterfly at a pool and just
go and then your tit falls out and then
everyone loves it it is because you're
like oh
that's like 16 that's coming over to see
you just I had those posters yes but I
think that um the trick with butterfly
is not in your arms it's your leg and
you have to have a strong sex okay like
the Rhythm too yeah like if you if you
kick once your second kick has to come
like it's not a one kick one you know
one pull one kick one pull it's one kick
poke second kick so I'll get you there
Annie
anyway so her mom was living with you
guys um yeah I but so I think you got
the Habit though and like in your head
your identity this is just like all my
hypnosis stuff your identity is of an
athlete and someone who exercises so
you're gonna feel like so bad if you
don't exercise right
um I've been pretty bad in the last
couple months right but that is probably
like three times a week which is average
and when I do work out it's like uh I'm
I'm working out like I'm not what are
you doing I'm lifting I break as well
no no no no but if I can if I'm doing 30
minutes or 45 minutes it's going to be a
hard consistent it's not taking breaks
to just like walk around no which I'm
trying to change I'm trying to be easier
on myself because I'm like what is the
point of all of this why is this
Dreadful so I'm trying to find ways that
are like you know what if this is a 30
minute workout but I can pause and even
if it takes me an hour and a half to get
through it at least I'm being nice to
myself in the process and you do you
feel more energized after you do it love
it I'm happy I make better decisions I'm
nicer to people I'm nicer to
um in my relation I'm more content in my
relationships it's it's really [ __ ] up
and psychological but I am so
chronically tired to the point where
sometimes I just it's hard for me to
immediately respond to emails yes
responsive text messages and they sit
there and I'm like why can't I just
[ __ ] reply to them well we know that
Bobby has the same problem but we know
it's not from exercise when did you get
diagnosed with this because I feel like
I really I'm relating to this so much of
just like my boyfriend comes home from
work and he once he's been working all
day longer than goes to work before me
right and then he gets home and he's
like let's go shopping for that blanket
you wanted to get let's go to the let's
go let's go for a walk to the beach
let's go and I'm like how do you want to
I wish I was someone who wanted to do
these exactly so I love your dogs no
because dog walking too that's the thing
that like I have to save my life and
it's like I have to do it and then I I
made a decision where I was like I I
when my boyfriend asked me to go out for
a walk with the dog I always say yes
even though I [ __ ] want to just lay
there and he's always like you can lie
and I'm like no because I want to go and
then the dog like wants us together it's
cute yeah it's like happy so I just have
to like force and then once I do it it's
fine I actually have more energy for
later things but it is like it's not I
think for me all of my laziness is
procrastination it's all like yes some
fear of something on the other end of
getting work done maybe or that I try to
think of it I'm like what is happening
here even when I procrastinate but truly
like my body does just it wants to like
be one with a bed yeah like I just
cannot get up and like you're saying
where it's like your boyfriend comes
home and he's still energized to do more
things I'm like how he's been holding
all those farts and he's got extra gas
he's ready to go I really do envy people
who wake up and then get [ __ ] done
because I work well in 50 minute
increments and big bursts that's nice to
know it's a good amount of time too but
you have so much time and then I need I
need a break so like when I have
meetings with George or the guys after
50 minutes there's a glaze that comes
over me and I'm just tired and I'm I've
completely checked out and I need to go
lie in bed yes yes and have my phone
like like this and put on white noise
and just go like oh and it's bright and
beautiful outside and there's a friend
that wants to go to lunch with me and
I'm like I can't I just need but how hot
is she
since I look at you and I'm so envious
of like how much you can get done in a
day like you're up and at them in the
morning that's so weird that people see
you in the exact opposite Place yourself
yeah and I think you're right because
people see me as like always busy I
don't think the same thing but you know
what it is it's because we don't reward
our wins we highlight our failures to
ourselves and it's like Bonnie McFarland
gave me the best advice the other day it
was like so weird and so like
it seems like bad advice but because I
do wake up so early a lot in the day it
becomes a problem where I'm like too
exhausted I don't I can't use my tools
I'm like I'm just like not fresh I'm not
getting stuff done the way I'm like
having anxiety because I'm just so tired
so she was like you need to start like
rewarding yourself for sleeping in so I
did it the other day where I was like I
was like oh my God you made it to 9 00
a.m like yes wow and then I like slept
till 10 and then I did have like this
great day because I did have like a busy
couple days coming up because I just get
so overwhelmed by there was like a thing
on I think it was daily stoics Instagram
and it said oh that guy he stresses me
out what he's like they're gonna die
remember you're gonna die yeah oh God
Marcus Aurelius said that you every
morning like he did he was always
breaking down things that the stoic said
like that that guy stresses me out he's
always getting things done he's like
writing eight books a day but it is also
like a family yeah he's like there's a
these people dump some trash I'm gonna
pick this up then I'm gonna write a book
and Marcus Aurelius said like and but
here's the thing he probably does the
same amount of stuff we do I know
because I want to see his down time
because we like I want to see everyone I
want to see people's down time I asked
my friends I'm on a Girl Scout with my
friends and I asked them the other day
take me through your day I want to see I
want to know what you do oh my God I'm
tired
my friends like to go like shopping at
like for new plants for their house or
they like to like that's why I don't
like when people go Nikki you need a day
off and I'm like a day off to you looks
like going to go to the grocery store to
meal plan and then making meals for the
whole week and then you know doing your
front stoop and making it putting up
decorations for Halloween like I think
days off to people are full of chores
and I don't I want a day off where it's
literally nothing and I don't think
those exist in America like you're a
lazy piece of [ __ ] if you our job would
allow us that though like it's just
would you allow yourself that because
well because our work does this is fun
like this doesn't feel like we're even
though it is but sometimes it does it
just depends it's a because it sometimes
it's like depending see those people
um
um I'm I see red flags and people who
are chronically busy
um really alert me in all of the wrong
ways especially if it's some somebody
that I'm interested in and I see a guy
who's always busy because someone asked
this question I don't know where I
forget what it was but are you healed or
are you just distracted and I think a
lot of people throw themselves in these
like busy work mode to try to not deal
with anything else in their lives it's
like are they gonna crash eventually
yeah so it's like or maybe I Otter's
like cry like I'll just like be like all
right I've been called or like I've been
I've maybe shamed myself into thinking
I've been lazy my whole life so much so
that before I date a guy seriously I
have to be like hey like I'm a lounger
like I have to tell them like I like to
loaf around and kind of chill so if
that's not like your thing like we're
just not gonna get along but kalila do
you have social anxiety or just not like
enjoy being out that much I love being
out I I feel exhausted when I talk to
people I'm not fully comfortable with
like I'm like like almost like Ken's
yeah like you like
like how many nights a week would you
have like what your birthday was last
year oh by the way when was your
birthday uh yesterday happy birthday I
knew it was round here
welcome to the club but I'm 39 now [ __ ]
oh my God I feel I always feel a year
older I'm just I get myself there so
that when it happens it doesn't yeah
yeah
enjoying it all it's awful yeah it's all
been good and a big night out no but I'm
thinking about like you're like so
kalila's birthday party last year was it
yeah was like a karaoke room and it was
like all of her friends and her family
and so it was like it's a lot of work
yeah but those are all the people that I
was very like I'm already super close
with so fun and easy so how many nights
a week would you do that if about a week
okay well I'm finding out
once every
once a year because I like going out so
much I guess so it's like I love going
on doing stand up so much that it's like
it wouldn't even like occur to me enough
but I feel like you are energized by
other people and you energize them back
and I don't feel that same way I feel
absolutely drained afterwards um but I'm
proud of myself after like yeah I come
home I'm like oh I did that I had that
but do you ever have I feel like you
have the dread of go of doing something
and then when you do it it's fun barely
not fun like it's rare that we really
get caught in a situation where we have
to talk to people that were like this
sucks I mean it's it happens but we I
think anticipate that more than it
really happens I think I dread every
single thing in my life yeah oh no I
have like over well this is what I'm
gonna say so the daily Stoka he had a
thing where it's like you're not
overwhelmed you're just not managing
your time but I think on top of that I
have my dread like
I just shot this thing this morning and
then I knew I was gonna have to shoot
this and I almost said no to this like
really fun thing that I did because I
was like wait I'm gonna have to get up
at five in the morning and then I'm also
gonna have to do something like in the
afternoon and then like who knows if I'm
gonna have to do a spot or whatever like
just the dread of being tired for one
day was like so much not getting enough
sleep and then I ended up like having so
much fun and I'm like [ __ ] I would have
been so sad if I didn't do that yeah and
it and it's like I always look at myself
like I'm burdened by my opportunities
like when people ask me to like do yeah
like they're like come be on my show or
something like like I I go through like
a whole like Spiral I hate it when it
happens because at first you're just
like I because I you feel that you feel
like you should say yes you know it will
be fun afterwards you know it yeah but
there's just that dread and that fear of
not getting enough sleep and um and also
just of
yeah I really just relate to not when
you get asked to do things I'm like how
[ __ ] freaking out about it and being
like how I'm like but then also not
having anything to do is uh horrifying
and I don't know what to do with my time
and thinking that someone else is doing
that thing like I just got jealous that
you've been up since five and you like
work today it was really fun like I'm
like I just got jealous I was like Nikki
you should have done a thing today why
did you turn that down it's like I just
sat and got like I got an IV drip today
because I needed one for this
inflammation I've been having and I just
was like sitting there and just like you
lazy piece of [ __ ] and they're like you
going to the spa getting a massage those
kind of things it's like the self-care
that we're all shamed into if you don't
do it you're shamed and then if you do
it I just feel guilt we have to stop
worrying about what other people are
saying to us and we should be like what
do we want like that's just like you
always have to silence that because it's
like you're never gonna no it's a
million people with a million ideas yeah
I think also it's the idea that you have
to um earn rest
yes is really really
my friend once said I was living with
she was he was the only person who I've
ever heard say I didn't earn that I
didn't earn a nap today and I'm she's
like what does that even mean I'm like
you can't just those are treats that's
dessert you have to eat your dinner
first I see that nap is the fuel though
the nap is the fuel yes yes I love and
you know what like I love sleeping me
too I love dreaming I don't know I love
it same I don't understand people are
like you know I'm like that is the one
of the most waking up after a deep
Lumber and having nothing to do
immediately and just sitting scrolling I
never give myself that feeling you know
scrolling I like sleeping I like being
in a bed with my partner next to me and
not talking to him when we're both on
Reddit I like all the things that you're
not stupid girl read it I've read it too
dark I know I love this intervention
that's where I get all this word from
Annie and I yeah no red is too far oh I
don't worry I don't I do my own
subreddits it's like Taylor Swift
yeah wait have you um listened to the
whole album oh duh it's a Memory okay so
uh midnight rain is like my favorite
song I Love It so much and it's so I
felt like there are so few songs that
women in like Taylor Swift is like her
stuff is so relatable but that one I'm
like oh I don't know that every woman
can relate to this because it talks
about like he was feeling comfortable I
was chasing that baby yeah she's like
chasing Fame pain he was comfortable I'm
like I don't know that I'd be like a
woman in the midwest being like chasing
that Fame Jason like and being able to
but I when I heard that song I was like
oh I relate they made it for me and
there's a song made for Esther it's
called Mastermind I swear oh that song I
haven't listened to the whole thing so
Mastermind is about tricking a guy into
please love into Mastermind and tell me
I dare you to not think of us I was I
was thinking about you though because by
the way you have completely merged
yourself isn't it funny that I did not
get a Taylor Swift Press Box that
[ __ ] Spencer Pratt got one like all
these people and they I've never I
follow them I'm like I've never seen you
post about Taylor Swift ever and I got
no I'm like I'll buy the things that
she's through in the Box it's already
teasing you I feel I cried I cried
because I was so hurt I was like not
that I want anything from her I don't
tag her in things I don't want to bother
her because I want her to be able to
create I don't want her I don't want to
meet her I don't need to have her go
like calm me down and like that's so
funny the idea that we thought you
needed her to calm you down
then you thought we were all like Nikki
places
and her just being like Oh think like
that's too much she could put that
towards us I wasn't it's not that I was
like I always like like Taylor Swift
songs and stuff but I never was like
like when you were obsessed with her I
was like okay Nikki that's like okay
that's your person you're obsessed with
or whatever I was listening to some of
the songs and I was like I get it
because it is like so inspirational that
she just did all this [ __ ] by herself
this way like it's like speaks to me I'm
just I'm so happy I have it it's so lit
I know it's so lame I can't it's not
just like it's just it feels like almost
the way like it feels like an identity
and then like as a white girl I don't
really have one like it's sad that that
has to be mine but I feel it just feels
it's something it's something I care
about more than anything well with the
competitiveness can you use her as like
would Taylor Swift have time to be
looking at this person's thing oh you
know what I mean you think that girl
that girl has I mean her new song
um uh anti-hero is about like hating
yourself yeah and always like reading
what everyone says and not ever being
enough imagine having that many fans and
reading them though that's like endless
there's one line there but she talks
about being a covert narcissist oh yeah
did you uh but the oh my God I can't
come up with it right now but the line
about like sometimes I feel like
everybody is a sexy baby and I'm a
monster on a hill and you're just like
oh and she's just like crawling around
in the music video like a big old
monster and like the fact that Taylor
Swift thinks she's a monster and that
they're sexy babies like there's she's
comparing herself she has this song
called nothing new with Phoebe
um Bridgers on her red album that if and
I know that you probably
Phoebe Bridger it is so good because
it's about being like we started out
young right we were like we got the
attention for being young and then you
start you go oh my God I'm not the young
one anymore I was getting attention for
being the young cute one and then you
become eclipsed by the next thing and
it's about people kind of like getting
tired of you there's just so much to
compare to but what was the did Mike did
you my covert narcissist and disguises
that one where it's like somebody
congressmen the the she goes did you
hear my covert narcissism I might
disguise as altruism oh my God so she's
acknowledging that she might be a covert
narcissist which is hugely I mean she's
more calling out people who've called
her that yeah but she's giving it a nod
to it and I felt like this album
of every single one before it I just
felt like man she is just digging it
made me want to be a more honest artist
well wasn't her like wasn't the wasn't
called midnights because it was like
different nights that kept her up yeah
stays up thinking about and I mean it is
cool to like break the fourth wall with
your audience and like let them see and
then her last song Dear reader so good
so she does this whole album that's just
like and we're just eating it up being
like she's I'll do anything Taylor Swift
said like for me I'm just like she's a
saint and then she go the last song is
called dear reader and it's like
don't trust a narrator who has problems
yeah basically don't don't take advice
from someone who's falling apart and I'm
falling apart clearly so like don't put
me on this pedestal and it was just like
and then our song and then Mastermind is
like I thought that was so honest to
admit that you like this thing that this
she's like sorry babe you thought it was
fate that we met that night like I I had
I planned it all yeah like us gently
touching in that crowded room that was
planned us like and she was and then it
just it just being just so honest and I
felt like she is someone that is very um
curated and she's been called
orchestrated which is just a way to call
like dismiss women like or calculated
it's like so I'm not supposed to plan
anything you know and so I think it was
just an answer to it and then pick where
we're gonna eat yeah but it's
um I was in her documentary like talking
[ __ ] about her yeah and it was like it
was uh wake up all the humans on Earth
so ironic that it happened that way but
I I care so much better I was like
because my friends go no way that she it
was just my voice going she's too thin
and all her model friends ugh enough
like I said something like that that's
so funny and it was during the 1989 era
when she was struggling with an eating
disorder she had all model friends I was
like she wouldn't let me be her friend
with the way I look right now and I was
just yeah I was like all just like yeah
and so I my friends were like there's no
way that's your voice like because it
was just my voice in the trailer and I
go I'm in this [ __ ] document and
there was like you would never say that
about her I'm like they're like you love
her she's like your best friend I go
yeah I've talked about you this way
[ __ ] like I this is the way you talk
about your friends when they get too
skinny and like get
do you
um how often have you had dreams where
you're hanging out with Taylor Swift
often yeah and you wake up hanging out
let's be honest I love that she works
with Jack Antonoff yes yeah the
bleachers and I think I always recommend
if you ever want to watch like a great
live show the bleachers is that yeah so
entertaining yeah he's so [ __ ] good
he's such a hot boy too yeah do you like
would you ever want to like work with
the people she's worked with do you have
eyes on that type of thing my friend
asked me the other day this is a good
question to ask yourselves if you could
get a call right now on your phone with
an opportunity or just any call really
and it in within reason you know
um what would it be what would be the
call what would they be saying what
would they be I'd still be like God damn
it why are you asking me to do something
I know I'm busy I can't make that movie
it's an interesting question because I
don't I don't want them of course I want
to be asked to host SNL at some point
but when that call comes in I'm gonna be
like God damn it like this is a lot oh
my God how much
it's going to be a hard yes this is when
America learns I'm not kidding I cannot
read yeah I just did a thing with um
Taryn Killam and and uh Bobby Moynihan
today and I it was like crazy to be like
reading prompter neck I was like oh God
you guys are [ __ ] so used to this
um before we're still learning to read
sorry before we and I wanted to ask you
guys this question that's been on my
brain which is
um a friend of mine's husband recently
got a vasectomy and she basically was
like I'm afraid that once he gets it
because they already have like a couple
kids together I'm afraid when when he
gets it I'm not going to be as like
sexually attracted to him anymore and is
there something to the our biology of
knowing that we could get pregnant from
someone that turns us on
the mount I like anal says no
she's got that Catholic girl in her
that's interesting though I I would have
never thought of that but that's a
really good because after the vasectomy
apparently you have to masturbate 50
times to make sure that you empty out
the gun completely I don't want to see a
medical masturbation okay like when they
are like a prescribed masturbation like
you got this how and also the the number
50 just seems like a wild guess to me
yeah like around 50. that's how much
that stuff sits around in there the
masturbation a lot but do you think that
like how do you would that change the
way you feel like I
I like that there's like a breeding
fetish yes get me pregnant there's like
a view it's hot I say it all the time I
don't want to get pregnant we do not we
you know there's no plan of that but
like it's brought up every single day
well I I when I sleep with boys I tell
them beforehand no matter what I say you
cannot come inside but nothing but then
during it's like give me that baby yeah
and I go pull them in but then
beforehand I'm like no matter what I
said before yeah and then you're like
yeah
so it's kind of like when your biology
takes over and you're in like the heat
of the mold yeah like you do want to be
[ __ ] into I think it feels better than
a nice inside I guess maybe the
vasectomy though you get to get [ __ ]
in and so maybe if you when you enter
the animal brain you're not thinking
about vasectomy he had it taken out it's
just come has come like any kind of
fluid in you or maybe I can still get
turned on knowing that it's reversible
yeah it's reversible and they're not
like 100 you're just like picturing them
going in for a [ __ ] reverse or maybe
like maybe the challenge of maybe him
still getting me pregnant even with a
vasectomy oh my God yeah like let's see
because there has been that before yes
yeah and just getting [ __ ] in Freely
like I think that without the fear of
actually yeah I think would but is that
hot is that less hot I think it's I
think you're right it's there's maybe we
can be odds
I love a slot machine
it doesn't look different right it's
still the same and taste this it's just
a little higher it's like a nose job
does have a little x's in their eyes
well you guys thank you so much for
watching us yet again for another
episode thank you so much Nick yes thank
you for having me yeah thanks for coming
back I just I'm sorry I didn't do the
Esther thing of sitting like this
and like you're wearing a really big
hiding her tits on her big shirt
disgusting [ __ ]
what
are you stupid [ __ ]
um it was so fun I love you guys yeah
thanks Nikki see you guys next week